Speaker 1: You know, we always say if only the
young people came out and voted, especially in the
midterms, look at what we could do. Well, we have
the numbers. 18 to 29 year olds saved the election
last Tuesday. There is a really great explanation
from John Della Volpe. I hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly, where Dela Volpe explains the simple
math. Okay, high turnout combined with 63% of 18
to 29 year olds voting for Democrats versus 35%
of that very same group voting for Republicans,
Gen Z and the younger millennials under 30
effectively canceled out every voter age 65 plus.
This is absolutely fascinating. And then when you
look at these groups, you look at 18 to 29 and you
look at 65 plus 18 to 29, had a plus three overall
contribution to the vote margin for Democrats and
65 plus had a minus three overall contribution
for Democrats. We always talk about the older
generations are significantly more right leaning
and there's just not enough young people voting
to cancel out or make up for that. That is exactly
what that is, literally what happened on November
8th. The very same three point contribution that
the 65 plus group overall made to Republicans was
eliminated. It was zeroed out. It was tethered,
as we might say, by 18 to 29 year olds who
contributed 80. Three point margin to Democrats.
It was their own future on the line. I wish that
they would vote more, and it's important to focus
on the fact that it's not record breaking numbers
necessarily that make the difference here. It's
that enough young people turned out to vote in
order to undo the significant right leaning effect
of the 65 plus group. At the end of the day,
53% of eligible voters voted in the 2018 midterms
in 2022. Only 27% of those in that youngest age
group voted. So consider that comparison. There
is so much headroom for that youngest group to get
more involved. And I know it's so cliche because
we always say, look at the math. If that young
group got more involved, they could wield so much
power and influence. Well, we are seeing in 18 to
29 year olds canceled out the 65 plus vote. The
red wave evaporated. It will maybe be a ripple.
And the amount of headroom that that group has to
single handedly decide elections is incredible.
We've just got to engage them. We've got to get
them involved. Make sure you're subscribed to our
YouTube channel. Very important. We're pushing for
2 million subscribers. We will be live tomorrow
night with Trump's announcement on YouTube,
Twitch and Facebook. Hope to see you there.
The David Pakman Show does depend on your support
to do what we do. I would love for you to sign up.
Join Pacman dot com. Become a member. It comes
with great benefits, it's very inexpensive and
it directly funds what we do. There is no other
parties taking big slices of every contribution
the way many of these large tech platforms do. 2%
goes to processing credit and debit cards a very
reasonable amount, and the rest actually stays
with us. You can sign up at join Packman dot
com and you can use the coupon code. 24 starts now
because it does and let's get to that right away.